US Attorney General William bar has been
holding a news conference detailing key
aspects of his release of the Malheur
report redacted copies of the special
counsels report on Russian election
interference are going to be made public
shortly now the Attorney General bar
says that the report confirms that no
Americans and no one in the Trump
campaign colluded with Russia to
influence the 2016 presidential election
on the question of whether President
Trump attempted to thwart the
investigation Barr said that he
concluded himself the president's
motives were non corrupt and that
influenced bars decision not to bring
charges or obstruction of justice this
morning let's have a quick listen into
part of what he said as the Special
Counsel report makes clear the Russian
government sought to interfere in our
election process but thanks to the
special counsels thorough investigation
we now know that the Russian operatives
who perpetrated these schemes did not
have the cooperation of President Trump
or the Trump campaign or the knowing
assistance of any other American for
that matter that is something that all
Americans can and should be grateful to
have confirmed from our let's bring in
DW correspondent Oliver salad who is
standing by in Washington and Oliver
what are we to make of what we just
heard the Attorney General say well
basically the Attorney General repeated
his summer idiot that he had published
just a couple weeks ago saying that
there was no conspiracy and also that
the model report did not have any
evidence for obstruction of justice
interestingly he now focused rather on
Russia than on Trump essentially taking
the pressure of the u.s. president
saying that only Russia meddled in the
2016 election he said that there is no
evidence that any American conspired or
coordinated with the Russian government
but at the same time that the Russian
government in fact meddled with the with
the 2016 election repeating that
is vindicated but what we're also going
to get from this report is a very
detailed blow-by-blow analysis and
report about the conduct of the US
president about tweets private threats
and so on and so it will be very
interesting to see and to which extent
this will actually damage his presidency
and this is an investigation I mean it
has really caused shockwaves in
Washington right just walk us through
why well first of all an investigation
into a sitting president is always a big
deal has always been and does not happen
happen very often last time was it was
the Star report about Bill Clinton and
before that was the Watergate affair now
in addition to to the fact that it's an
investigation on a sitting president it
is about the question it was about the
question whether a foreign government
meddled in a democratic election in the
2016 election in the United States now
many say that this meddling even caused
Donald Trump's victory that he would not
be the u.s. president without the
Russian support and another aspect
obviously is Donald Trump's conduct and
his very suspicious behavior as
especially the Democrats say which is
that he fired FBI director James Comey
just after he launched the Russia
investigation he later fired Jeff
Sessions his his Attorney General for
refusing himself of this investigation
he replaced him them with William bar of
much more favorable Attorney General and
Democratics the Democrats criticized
that this is partisan politics that
they're playing right now yeah
absolutely partisan politics and also I
mean what you're really seeing with the
release of this report is the art of the
spin as well because you know those
Democrats they've claimed that the news
conference that we've just seen from the
Attorney General is basically the
government's way of spinning the
narrative ahead of the reports release
just walk us through how both sides are
playing this Oliver
well the Democrats at Congress were very
furious about the fact that the Attorney
General was going to deliver this press
conference in his remarks actually
before publishing the report and so
yesterday the chairs of several
congressional committees sat together
and demanded that this really be
canceled they criticized in particular
that that as you just said that the
Attorney General would give this report
a spin before it was published
reportedly members of the Department of
Justice informed the White House to some
extent which would have given Trump's
lawyers certain preparation time to be
ready to have the adequate answers to
all accusations resulting out of this
report right now and this is basically
what's criticized also the date of
course tomorrow is Good Friday where a
head of a holiday weekend in the United
States with limited room for the
Democrats to respond to this it promises
to be an action-packed day in Washington
there Oliver salad on the story for us
thank you